Hello. Bonjour. Good morning.
Uh thank you for having me.
I'm Jonathan Hurst. I'm chief robot
officer at Agility Robotics. Uh this is
our machine, Digit, humanoid robot. And
I'm going to talk today a little bit
about um how we go from the ambition of
having humanoid robots that are part of
everyday human life, multi-purpose,
useful in many, many places.
Um but how we start with that. How we
have real-world impact right up front on
our path towards this this big dream.
I think that this is the best crowd to
really um agree with me and not argue
too much that embodied AI is the future
of labor.
We're going to have machines that can
physically do most of the things that
people can do, and then many, many more
things beyond that. And that's going to
fundamentally change how we do labor.
Now, today, it starts in things like
logistics and warehousing and simple
simple, more focused tasks. But over
time, it's going to gradually broaden
towards more manipulation tasks, better
and better dexterity, and other things
to get out into more and more broad
markets.
And there's two big, main ways in which
I believe that embodied AI, broadly, but
also humanoids, are going to impact our
economy. Number one is basic capacity.
Just the limit that many of these
industries have on the services that
they can provide to customers because
there are not enough people to do the
jobs and do the roles. Especially with
demographics changing and especially
with population shifting, uh this is a
really important one. But also basic
capability. You can ask the question,
"How many blacksmiths does it take to
build a laptop?" And of course,
blacksmiths can't build laptops. You
have to ladder up the technology to get
to the point of creating something like
that. And embodied AI is going to do
that. Now, that's the hardest to
predict. It's hardest to know what we
are going to be building in the future
that these embodied AIs allow us to
build, but I do believe that this is
going to be a major
important factor in our economy.
So, the big question is really important
to ask, and it's important for anybody
building humanoids to ask this is why
are why a humanoid? And um is it even
the right way to do it, or should it be
something else? And I would say we are
building human-centric robots because we
want to operate in human environments.
And this is really a new era of
robotics. Robots in the past have really
had to you've had to design the
environment around the robots.
Industrial robot arms, you design the
process, even AMRs, autonomous mobile
robots, you have to have an environment
and a space that's really suited for the
robots. But having human-centric robots
is what allows them to be much much more
general purpose, more multi-purpose
because so many workflows have been
designed around us. We've designed the
workflows around us. So, having a robot
that can just walk in and do that
workflow is very very useful.
Now, we have also found at Agility as
we've really looked into this that it is
useful to have kind of a rough form
factor like a person. You want two arms
to pick up big things.
Um you need to be balancing in order to
be able to lift big things up high and
do it in narrow spaces like hallways and
go through doorways. Uh to do that, you
have to be balancing. Uh you have to be
dynamically stable. And a pair of legs
is the best way to be dynamically
stable. Legs can be more stable than any
other solution that we've seen or that
we know about in order to be balancing.
So, upright torso, balancing, bipedal,
two legs, and bimanual, two arms. And
then because this is human-centric,
having a face, having something to be
able to interact with people. But that's
kind of where I think some of the
similarities may end.
And a big question is on hands. We see
so many five-fingered hands, for
example, but why are we building
five-fingered hands? I don't believe
anybody knows the answer to that. Um
dexterity is one of the grand challenges
in robotics. Uh we don't do it well in
robotics right now, certainly nowhere
near human dexterity. And I think when
you copy it, it's kind of like the the
Disney Hall of Presidents. It's an
animatronic. It maybe looks on the
outside a bit like a person, but it's
missing all of the most important things
like force control and compliance. And
of course, the intelligence in order to
create that dextrous behavior, even if
the hardware is physically capable.
We found with Digit, for example, there
was no five-fingered hand on the market
that could do what it does. It's lifting
25 kg bins. It's very difficult,
actually, to grasp it like that. And so,
we did build very powerful, strong
manipulators. Um but we have generality
because now you can swap manipulators
out. A humanoid robot has the ability to
use different tools for its task.
Now, I think down the road we may be
going by two or three fingers to start
with.
We see in like the Cybathlon, which is a
competition in Europe where disabled
people can augment themselves
technologically by adding whatever uh
they want. And so, amputees can have
manipulators. And then they do a
manipulation challenge, which is just
measuring pragmatically, what can they
do? And the winner the last 2 years has
been a parallel jaw gripper, a very
simple parallel jaw gripper with a one
or two degree of freedom wrist. So, that
tells us something about if we really
want to achieve dexterity, we've got to
think about this from the first
principles approach and not just copy
the way that people look.
Now, the intelligence is a huge part
also of how you need to solve this grand
challenge of manipulation and whole body
control and locomotion, all of these
things.
And I think it's very important to point
out that there is no single silver
bullet. There is no black box of AI.
There is a big tent of computational
tools that are all very valuable in um
creating the behaviors that we want. And
different tools are useful in different
locations. So, I already talked about
the hardware really has to be special.
Um, you have to get the physics right of
the mechanical system. It has to be
back-drivable, have good force control,
be able to have good compliant
interaction with the world to make it
even possible for any software, no
matter what it is, in order to um,
locomote and and manipulate things in
the world. Um, at the high level, at the
very top of this stack, we see large
language models and vision language
models and things like that that can be
trained off of the entire internet. Um,
and that helps with context and solves
perception and so many things. But, it
cannot control an individual robot. It
cannot control the torques to all of the
individual motors
um, at every instant in time given the
particular sensor inputs cuz there is no
source of data that provides examples or
correct examples of that. That has to be
discovered. So, there's two ways to do
that. One is you teach the robot via
teleoperation or animation or motion
capture or other examples. And we see
that for teaching the robot sort of
complex skills. How do you grasp things?
A learning from demonstration. But, then
robots have to practice. Robots have to
use reinforcement learning in simulation
and real life um, on physical robots in
order to refine that in order to
actually get to the high performance
that that robot is going to be able to
achieve beyond what a person controlling
a robot would be able to do.
So, all of these things, there's a lot
here.
So, the question is how do we get to
this? If we solve these grand challenges
in robotics, we can have these machines
working with us and helping us in our
homes. I certainly hope to have this um,
by the time
uh, within my lifetime. Uh, but today we
can start with picking up bins, picking
up totes, um, doing things in warehouses
and logistics, doing useful work that
customers are willing to pay for right
now that provides a return on investment
and lets us learn all of the very hard
things about deploying robots. There's a
lot about um information security, about
all the metrics of uptime and servicing
these robots, and
um safety is the big one I'll talk
about.
So, we have deployed Digit uh doing work
like this is in a GXO warehouse. You can
see that Digit is picking up bins off of
the autonomous mobile robot and putting
it on a conveyor belt. This is something
we've been doing for almost 2 years now,
and um this is this is a commercial
deployment.
Here it is at Amazon stacking totes. You
can see it's a different workflow, but
very similar in many ways. So, we're
kind of scoping a multi-purpose task
within a range of scope and can
gradually build that scope over time.
Here it is at uh Schaeffler loading, you
know, dirty oily parts into a a washing
machine. So, these are fairly heavy.
These bins are sometimes damaged.
They're always a little bit different.
They're always a little bit different
weight. They're shifting weight inside
of it. Um
and and Digit's just doing this basic
workflow.
So, what's the real blocker? Yes, we've
deployed and we've been deployed for a
couple of years, but really it's it's
safety.
Um I'll go back a couple and see there's
a work cell around this robot. There's a
physical barrier that is separating this
machine from any people that would be
nearby.
This is the only way that we can operate
within the existing regulatory
environment that we know of.
Uh any dynamically stable, any balancing
machine is going to need to be behind a
physical barrier like this, which really
limits its utility. A robot that has to
be in a cage is not very multi-purpose.
It's not utilizing the benefit that a
humanoid robot can actually utilize.
Being human-centric requires being safe.
It requires being able to go out into
unmodified human environments, and
safety is the blocker right now because
these robots can do the physical work.
So, step step one well, I'll start with
this.
You know the robots will fall. That's
unavoidable. That has to be acceptable.
It has to be okay if a robot, you know,
the robot can't land on somebody's foot
and cause even a basic injury like that.
Basic pinch point kinds of things,
right?
Um but beyond the basic pinch points and
hot surfaces and the robot falling,
judgment errors when a robot is making
intelligent decisions in an environment.
Like you don't want it to pour hot
coffee in your lap or start the dryer
when there's a kid hiding in there
because they're playing hide-and-seek or
any number of things like that that we
haven't begun to envision. The world
hasn't begun to envision yet, but will
be necessary before we can deploy these
in homes and environments like that.
And there's a lot of rules about even
social rules, but also basic safety
rules. A robot has to make intelligent
choices about whether it touches you on
the shoulder or the eyeball. And which
one is okay. And it has to do that not
just 90% of the time, but in sort of a
statistically, you know, true 99. some
number of nines percent uh validated by
third parties
uh such that insurance companies can
understand the risk that they're
undertaking. It is a huge very, very
high bar
to get there. And they cannot do this
now.
So, step one is operate inside of the
safety cage. But a whole bunch of other
things like a control pendant, safety
rated power electronics, safety rated
data bus so that when you hit the e-stop
you have a a well-known and
well-understood behavior that again a
third party has validated. It's not just
you stating that this should work. It's
somebody else who's gone through this
design with a fine-tooth comb and it's a
lot of certification.
Step two
and this is what Agility is releasing
later this year with our Digit V5 robot
is a machine that can detect people
around it and change its behavior as
people approach. So, the robot can slow
down, it can stop what it's doing, set
its load down on the ground, and even
get down on the ground and sit down and
turn power off before a person can touch
the robot. This allows a robot to get
outside of a safety cage, outside of a
work cell, and still operate in human
environments, in human spaces, near and
among humans.
Now, that's a necessary step in order to
get to step three, which is where we'd
really like to go, is robots being able
to make those intelligent decisions
about what they can touch and how they
can touch them. And we believe that this
is going to follow a similar path to
what we've seen from autonomous
vehicles. Now, in autonomous vehicles,
we had safety drivers and collected
millions of hours of data and start to
be able to predict what a pedestrian or
a bicyclist will do and be able to react
appropriately to that in a way that
actually allows these robots to be
autonomous. Now, of course, with a
humanoid, the complexity is vastly
greater than cars on the road. Cars have
two degrees of freedom. They can go
faster and slower, and they can steer
right and left. Humanoids, of course,
have so many more degrees of freedom.
And roads are far more structured than
homes and workplaces and social rules in
human environments.
And we cannot have safety drivers on a
on a robot. There's no real way to have
a robot be safe and also productive if
you have a person controlling it the
whole time.
So, that's why I say step two is
important because now we can have a
fleet of thousands and thousands of
robots deployed doing useful work,
collecting data, while we build the
safety setup for the intelligent
decision making of a robot and build the
statistical case that shows reliably
that these robots do what we expect them
to do and make the intelligent choices.
That's how we get to robots that operate
safely among us in human environments
and even get to the point where you can
hand them something and physically
interact with a humanoid robot, which is
not possible today.
So, we want to start with what robots
can do right now, and that's logistics
and warehousing and that kind of
semi-structured industrial work that's
still too unstructured for automation to
serve right now. People are still doing
this task, but Digit can walk in and
start doing this job and be a source of
automation
without installing additional
infrastructure. And then, we continue to
build out the use cases in terms of each
picking and dexterous manipulation and
safety
and get into broader and broader markets
and start to cover more and more of kind
of the general labor and doing physical
work in the world. This is the path.
In order to get to broad, in order to
achieve this general-purpose dream, we
need to start with focus. We need to
start If you're going to do 100 use
cases, you start with one use case, and
then two, and then three, and you work
your way up. And what's really exciting
about humanoids that is not the case
with autonomous vehicles, an autonomous
car has to be fully safe and fully
autonomous and above a certain bar
before it's useful. A humanoid robot can
be in more semi-structured environments
today and step out of the work cell
today and be useful and get to the scale
of hundreds of thousands of robots and
be a huge market even very early here in
doing logistics and warehousing and
manufacturing and and that sort of
thing. Um but then, building on all of
that, you start to expand out into
retail markets, and you imagine a robot
working in a grocery store
palletizing, depalletizing in the back,
but then also unpacking boxes and coming
out and being able to stock shelves and
being able to start to operate close to
people. And then, through that path,
eventually getting to the point of
hospitals and construction sites and
home and everything else.
Um and that's where I'd like to stop.
Thank you for your attention. Uh we're
very excited about humanoids getting out
into the world.
Thank you.